can you define the word magician ah yes
the definition of a magician is someone
who sees patterns that others cannot see
and someone who creates patterns where
they did not exist before the magician
has that wonderful point of view
perspective and can grasp what's going
on it would seem almost magical but a
lot of it is perspective and the wisdom
dark wisdom or light wisdom but to see
what's going on to see patterns and then
to move things around through their
words through their magical spells
through their seductive influence
manipulation of others to create new
patterns whether it's going in and
corrupting a town or in fact there's a
wonderful old film starring andy
griffith and is called a face in the
crowd and it's a great example of
someone doing just that this one person
going in and corrupting the political
system so a face in the crowd with Andy
Griffith great example of what we're
talking about here so that the dark
magician at work in mid-century American
politics
you